angelina jolie is busting a move in the
name of education
[Music]
the actress joins her 17 year old
daughter zahara for a happy dance in
honor of her eldest girl accepting a
spot at spelman college
and when your kiddo goes off to college
naturally you break out the electric
slide
the video shared by writer director and
speaker brandon rainey has gone
completely viral angelina flexes her
skills on the dance floor but then
rushes off to give zahara a big hug
before sending her off
she's growing up so beautifully angie is
giving total proud mom energy sharing
zahara's news on instagram over the
weekend she posted this pic with some of
her classmates writing in the caption
zahara with her spelman sisters
congratulations to all new students
starting this year the actress calls
spellman a very special place and says
it's an honor to have zahara attending
the prestigious university i'm so
excited i feel like my world expands as
their world expands
i learned so much from them and yeah i'm
i love this stage but this isn't
angelina's first time sending one of her
kiddos off to college i just sent one
off but he was so i'm so proud of him
back in 2019 she got emotional when
dropping off her eldest son maddox at
yonsei university in south korea
i know
i'm trying
and we're sure for the mom of six
emptying her nest isn't gonna get any
easier it's gonna be different for
different kids
maddox was so
ready at the time she spilled all about
the bittersweet parting to e.t have you
stopped crying yet
no
did you have the ugly cry i can't
imagine angelina having it okay but did
you have the ugly girl like embarrass
your children ugly cry
i more did like i just i also just at
some point at the big glasses and i
think it was like the amount of times i
turned and waved it was like i do know
it was the one moment in my life i think
i turned around
six times and he sweetly stayed
and kept waving knowing that i was gonna
keep turning her you could feel that he
he knew he couldn't leave
along with maddox and zahara angelina
shares vivienne knox shiloh and pax with
estranged husband brad pitt i love being
a mommy i love my kids the actress has
always been vocal about the bond she
shares with her kids when your children
are your best friends it's kind of a
it's a nice life and the bond the kids
have amongst each other
i'm lucky and i think when you have that
many children
they they really take care of each other
they help me i'm not
i'm not alone managing everything they
are
an amazing team so i'm very very
fortunate
[Music]